vous savez ce que c'est ça
ça vous savez ce que c'est
et ça
bon c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
mais ça a quand même des gros points
communs on va parler de ça tout de suite
mais juste avant cette vidéo est
sponsorisée par panda craft vous vous
souvenez ils étaient déjà là pour ma
vidéo sur les conséquences du
dérèglement climatique sur la santé que
je vous invite à retourner voir ils font
des kits créatifs et scientifiques pour
les enfants jusqu'à 12 ans là ils en ont
un sur la vision mais ils font aussi
plein d'autres trucs on en parle à la
fin de la vidéo je vais même un cadeau
pour vous allez générique
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va parler des illusions
d'optique et on va notamment parler du
fait qu'elle porte très mal leur nom
vous allez voir mais avant de voir
comment ça marche on va se mettre un peu
dans l'ambiance voilà une illusion
d'optique ça donne ça par exemple
celle-là c'est des serpents tournants
d'akiyoshi qui t'avocat et si vous
déplacez votre regard sur l'image vous
allez voir les cercles tournés alors
qu'en fait non c'est juste une illusion
voilà ça c'en est une autre toujours des
serpents en tournant toujours le même
truc si vous regardez dans un coin les
cercles de l'autre côté ils vont se
mettre à tourner et si vous regardez les
cercles qui bougent bah ils vont arrêter
de bouger et dans le même genre il y a
aussi celle là qu'on appelle les graines
tournantes si vous voulez mon avis ça
ressemble pas beaucoup plus à des
graines que les autres semblent à des
serpents mais bon ça rend dingue cette
vidéo est sponsorisée par Desigual
en regardant cette image vous avez
sûrement plissé les yeux ou cligner des
yeux ou alors vous les avez frottés et
puis vous les avez fermé très fort avant
de les rouvrir en tout cas vous avez
fait quelque chose en vous disant bon
sang joue des tours ou quoi oui
apparemment vous avez 75 ans
et pourtant vous avez eu beau triturer
vos yeux quand vous les avez ouvert
c'était toujours là et ça bougeait
toujours alors qu'en fait non
mais en fait la raison elle est très
simple vos yeux ils y sont pour rien eux
ils ont fait leur job bon avant de voir
d'autres exemples d'illusions d'optique
on va faire un petit focus sur la façon
dont on voit pour bien comprendre
pourquoi des fois ça déconne quand on
regarde quelque chose nos yeux ils
reçoivent des informations sur la
lumière qu'il l'aurait renvoyé et nos
yeux il fonctionne un peu comme un
appareil photo bon en vrai c'est
l'inverse vu que nos yeux ils existaient
avant les appareils photos mais vous
avez l'idée la pupille là au milieu
c'est le diaphragme elle s'ouvre et elle
se ferme en fonction de la luminosité
quand il y en a beaucoup elle rétrécit
et quand il y en a pas beaucoup elle se
dilate quand elle est très serrée comme
ici en haut ça s'appelle un myosis et
quand elle est très dilatée comme là en
bas c'est une mydriase bon c'est pas
toujours à cause de la lumière mais
c'est pas le sujet du jour la lumière
une fois qu'elle est passée par la
pupille elle passe à travers le
cristallin cette espèce de lentilles
transparente là qui fait la mise au
point ouais nos yeux ils ont l'autofocus
et il fait converger la lumière vers le
fond sur la rétine qui est un petit peu
la pellicule de nos yeux ah bah oui
c'est un vieux modèle c'est de
l'argentique truc marrant à ce moment là
l'image elle est projetée à l'envers
peut-être en bas c'est à cause de la
forme du cristallin qui est arrondi on
dit biconvex vous savez c'est comme
quand vous regardez de loin à travers
une loupe ou une boule de cristal mais
bon le cerveau fait automatiquement la
correction donc au final on voit à
l'endroit et oui parce que toutes ces
infos sur la lumière que notre œil
reçoit elles sont ensuite transformées
en message électrique par les cellules
de notre rétine qui s'appelle les
photorécepteurs en grec photo ça veut
dire lumière donc photos graphie j'écris
avec la lumière et photos récepteur je
reçois la lumière donc ce message codé
par nos cellules il est transmis au
cerveau grâce au nerf optique mais notre
cerveau c'est pas une imprimante ou un
écran il se contente pas de transformer
le message électrique en images comme ça
bêtement il faut aussi que ces images
elles aient un sens
et quand elles en ont pas bah il en
trouve
il essaye et puis surtout comme il a
plein d'infos à analyser en même temps
que le processus est un peu complexe et
qu'il faut qu'il agisse quasi
instantanément bah parfois ça bug les
infos quand elles arrivent dans notre
cerveau elles sont envoyées au cortex
visuel là à l'arrière de notre crâne
dans le lobe occipital et puis elles
sont envoyées aux différentes aires
visuelles c'est-à-dire aux différentes
zones où elles vont être décodées en
fonction de ce qu'elles contiennent par
exemple les infos sur les formes elles
vont être décodées par l'air n°3 celle
sur les couleurs par leur numéro 4 et
celle qui concerne le mouvement par la
numéro 5 et c'est principalement à ce
moment là et dans ces endroits là que
les illusions d'optique vont naître une
illusion d'optique c'est une erreur de
perception qui nous fait voir quelque
chose qui colle pas à la réalité parce
que comme on l'a dit quand notre cerveau
comprend pas ce qu'on lui envoie il
essaye de rectifier le tir pour que ça
colle avec quelque chose qui connaît et
au final l'image qui nous renvoie donc
ce qu'on voit bah c'est pas vraiment ce
qu'on a en face de nous et comme ces
infos que notre cerveau comprend pas
elles sont traitées par les différentes
aires visuelles dont on vient de parler
bah il y a plusieurs types d'illusions
et plusieurs façons de les classer aussi
globalement elles sont liées aux
problèmes de perception des formes des
couleurs et des mouvements mais plus
largement elles impliquent aussi des
notions de contraste de dimension de
perspective de profondeur etc bon mais
le mieux c'est de prendre quelques
exemples tenez là 2 quelle couleur sont
les boules vertes rouges et bleu et ben
pourtant si on retire les lignes de fond
elles sont toutes de la même couleur en
fait ce qui se passe c'est que notre
cerveau automatiquement il rapproche la
couleur des boules de celle des lignes
qui sont au premier plan d'ailleurs on
s'en rend bien compte si on change la
superposition des lignes par rapport aux
boules alors que si on met juste les
boules par dessus ok cette phrase est
chelou n'empêche que si on fait ça voilà
ça s'appelle l'effet confettis ça a été
mis au point par le professeur David
novic de l'Université du Texas à El Paso
je vous mets le lien vers son compte
Twitter dans la description si ça vous
intéresse c'est un pote d'akiyoshi qui
Taoka le mec des serpents tournants ça
doit être sympa leur soirée mais faut
pas être épileptique
alors je vais vous avouer deux trucs la
première c'est que bon je fais le malin
depuis tout à l'heure mais en vrai pour
moi tout ça ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens
vu que je suis daltonien c'est pas une
illusion d'optique daltonien c'est juste
que j'ai des photos récepteurs qui
déconnent des cônes si vous voulez tout
savoir des cônes qui déconnent et la
deuxième c'est qu'on sait pas exactement
pourquoi le cerveau fait ça mais ça se
rapproche pas mal d'un autre phénomène
qu'on connaît depuis longtemps
l'illusion de White là vous voyez on a
l'impression que les rectangles de
gauche sont plus foncés que cette droite
alors qu'en fait il y a aussi la version
en couleur qui s'appelle l'effet de
munker et qui s'appuie sur l'effet de
besolve petite illustration
donc là notre cerveau ne trompe sur les
couleurs à cause des couleurs mais il
peut aussi nous tromper toujours à cause
des couleurs mais sur le mouvement cette
fois regardez bien cette image et dites
moi combien il y a d'éléments qui
bougent il y en a un seul celui-là votre
cerveau il reçoit tellement d'infos sur
les couleurs que ça fait bugger la zone
responsable du mouvement et vous avez
l'impression que tout bouge alors que
faites le test mettez un repère sur
votre écran genre un doigt et vous allez
voir que tout est complètement immobile
et ça marche avec toutes les heures
visuels bien sûr on a parlé des couleurs
et du mouvement il nous reste les formes
genre là si je vous dis que les lignes
horizontales sont droite et parallèles
entre elles vous allez me déronner déjà
prenez une pastille à la menthe et puis
surtout arrêtez parce que j'ai raison
prenez une règle si vous voulez vérifier
voilà j'ai raison là encore le phénomène
qui amène à cette distorsion dans la
perception des formes il est super
complexe et on se l'explique pas encore
complètement mais il y a deux choses qui
entre en jeu le contraste d'abord on a
d'un côté des carreaux noirs d'un autre
des carreaux blancs et le ciment du
carrelage il est entre les deux en
termes de teinte il est gris pour que ça
marche il faut qu'il soit plus clair que
les uns et plus foncés que les autres on
sait que ça joue parce que regardez si
on inverse le noir et le gris
ça marche plus par contre ça marche
aussi en couleur du moment qu'on
respecte la règle de la teinte
intermédiaire voilà et ça ça me permet
de vous donner la deuxième règle il faut
que les carreaux soient légèrement
décalés s'ils sont bien alignés ça
marche pas autre truc marrant plus
l'image et petite plus l'illusion est
forte voilà c'est une illusion d'optique
assez connue elle s'appelle l'illusion
du mur du café ouais parce que elle a
été décrite à partir du carrelage de ce
bistrot à Bristol dans les années 70
était déjà connu mais c'est ce qui lui a
donné son nom avant ça les clients
pensaient que c'était un autre truc qui
déformait ce qu'il voyait sûrement
après les illusions d'optique ça peut
aussi mettre en jeu d'autres notions un
tout petit peu différentes par exemple
ça arrive que un petit peu comme avec
l'illusion de White notre cerveau se
fasse avoir parce qu'il entoure un objet
mais cette fois pour analyser ces
dimensions un cercle entouré de petits
cercles à toujours l'air plus grand que
le même cercle entouré de cercle plus
grand ça a l'air compliqué mais regardez
l'image c'est évident un peu comme les
gens qui traînent qu'avec des moches
pour avoir l'herbe BG je sais vous
faites ça
et parfois aussi votre cerveau il va se
faire avoir en essayant de gagner du
temps ou parce qu'il manque de temps
comme on a dit tout à l'heure quand il
voit ça par exemple il va partir du
principe que les deux cadres ils font la
même taille ils sont tout droit et ils
sont sur la même ligne du coup ça va lui
faire tout drôle quand il va avoir ça en
fait il a pas été plus loin que ce qui
lui paraissait le plus logique donc il a
pas du tout été se dire que peut-être il
y avait un effet de perspective spoiler
il y avait un effet de perspective en
fait
dans ces deux derniers cas on se rend
compte que l'environnement de l'objet
joue un rôle dans l'analyse que notre
cerveau fait de l'image un coup il en
tient trop compte un coup il en tient
pas assez compte mais dans tous les cas
ça joue je pourrais encore vous donner
1000 exemples d'illusion d'optique comme
ça de la plus simple comme celle-là
l'illusion de zolmer à la plus complète
oui parce que vous connaissez les êtres
humains quand ils sont rendus compte
qu'il y a moyen de se cramer le cerveau
ils sont pas privés il y en a même qui
sont donnés du mal
on dirait des pochettes de timing pala
non
avant de vous laisser convulser
tranquille je voulais juste vous parler
de deux trucs un peu particuliers
d'abord les objets impossibles c'est un
peu différent parce que là c'est pas des
formes géométriques qui vous font
vriller le cerveau c'est des objets qui
ont été spécialement imaginé pour ça des
objets imaginaires donc des dessins bon
est-ce que vous savez ce que c'est un
BLV c'est ça si vous regardez à droite
pas de souci l'objet il se sépare en
deux parties mais si vous regardez à
gauche voilà il en a trois et si vous le
regardez en entier bah vous comprenez
pas ce que vous voyez voilà c'est ça un
objet impossible et on a plein d'autres
comme le triangle de Penrose mais on va
pas tous les citer vous avez compris le
principe le principe c'est de vous
rendre dingue et ça marche parce que
votre cerveau il veut absolument trouver
du sens là où il y en a pas et donc il
projette sur un dessin donc des traits à
plat des volumes donc un objet qui en
fait peut pas exister un peu comme
l'éléphant du début
dans le même ordre d'idée il y a la
Chambre d'AMS c'est une pièce qui est
pas du tout cubique mais dont les murs
le sol et le plafond ont été imaginés de
façon à ce qu'on pense que c'est le cas
si on regarde de loin et encore plus si
on la regarde à travers un trou tout ça
en jouant avec la perspective la
profondeur etc même pour le carrelage au
niveau du sol donc non seulement on
croit que la pièce est bien droite et
bien carrée alors que pas du tout mais
en plus quand des gens se cale dans les
coins tout au fond
et ben oui vous rendez compte le niveau
de fourberies qu'il faut avoir pour
inventer un truc pareil quel indemnité
donc là on a vu des trucs directement
sortis de l'esprit d'un être humain qui
aime bien se faire du mal et faire du
mal aux autres mais il y a aussi des
phénomènes complètement naturels qui
nous font voir des choses qui n'existent
pas non vous voyez pas pourtant c'est la
première image que je vous ai montré au
tout début de la vidéo un truc que vous
avez sûrement tout et tous déjà vu mais
qui n'existe pas vraiment non
arc-en-ciel un arc-en-ciel c'est juste
de la lumière qui passe à travers des
gouttelettes en suspension dans l'air
soit parce qu'il a plu soit parce que
vous êtes à côté d'une chute d'eau par
exemple cette lumière c'est de la
lumière blanche mais en réalité elle est
composée de plusieurs lumières de
couleur différente et elle est
décomposée en chacune d'entre elles
quand elles passent à travers les
gouttelettes en question qui joue le
rôle d'un prisme avec petite pochette de
Pink Floyd ce coup là
bon alors est-ce qu'un arc-en-ciel c'est
vraiment une illusion d'optique
techniquement c'est un phénomène optique
ça c'est sûr on voit clairement des
bandes de couleurs mais elles sont pas
là matériellement dans le ciel néanmoins
bon en vrai est-ce qu'on s'en foutrait
pas un petit peu ça ressemble pas mal à
un mirage quand même et est-ce qu'un
mirage c'est pas une illusion d'optique
bah le Larousse Dixie alors bon ah oui
tiens d'ailleurs les mirages vous savez
comme quand on voit de l'eau sur la
route l'été alors que en fait il y a pas
du tout de Flac là pour le coup c'est
encore un phénomène optique mais cette
fois il est lié à la chaleur d'ailleurs
on appelle ça un mirage chaud un mirage
inférieur aussi vu que le mirage a lieu
vers le bas vers le sol en fait quand il
fait très chaud la route elle est très
chaude et la chaleur qu'elle dégage sa
forme une couche d'air chaud au niveau
du sol de l'air beaucoup plus chaud que
la couche d'air qui est juste au dessus
vous avez compris que c'est chaud ou je
remets un petit coup ça crée une
différence de densité entre les couches
d'air parce que l'air chaud il est
beaucoup moins dense que l'air froid et
ça donne ce qu'on appelle la réfraction
terrestre en gros les rayons lumineux
ils sont déviés vers le sol et ça
projette ce qu'il y a au dessus ça donne
un effet miroir que notre cerveau
analyse comme
ça se réfléchit dans une flaque d'eau
évidemment parce qu'il essaye de trouver
une explication logique toujours un truc
qui connaît et qui comprend c'est aussi
ce qui donne cette impression de flou un
petit peu comme si l'air ondulé là vous
savez il y a d'autres types de mirage
comme ce bateau qui flottent dans les
airs ce coup-là c'est un mirage
supérieur c'est vrai que c'est
exactement la même chose sauf que c'est
l'inverse mais si vous comprenez la
l'aire qui a la surface de l'eau il est
plus frais c'est logique donc les rayons
lumineux ils sont courbés dans l'autre
sens et ils sont projetés vers le haut
et du coup l'image miroir elle est
au-dessus attention ça c'est des mirages
donc c'est des phénomènes optiques c'est
pas des hallucinations les
hallucinations c'est des images qui sont
100% créées par notre esprit à partir de
rien et bon en général c'est pas bon
signe
en tout cas c'est signe qu'il faut en
parler alors deux petits trucs chez vous
pour vous aider à faire la différence si
vous êtes pas sûr une hallucination déjà
en général vous êtes la seule personne à
la voir
sauf dans des cas très particuliers tout
simplement une hallucination collective
et puis un truc qui marche encore mieux
pour être sûr prenez une photo les
hallucinations sur les photos elles
apparaissent pas alors que les illusions
d'optique et les mirages si voilà pour
résumer vous avez compris dans les
illusions d'optique il y a une partie
qui s'explique physiologiquement
c'est-à-dire concrètement par la façon
dont notre corps traite les images mais
il y a aussi une composante
psychologique parce que notre cerveau
quand il analyse tout ça pour trouver un
sens à ce qui comprend pas il va aller
chercher dans nos souvenirs dans nos
connaissances dans nos expériences dans
nos croyances dans notre culture etc
c'est pour ça qu'on voit pas tous et
toutes les mêmes choses à chaque fois
comme cette danseuse par exemple il y en
a qui la voit tourner dans le sens des
aiguilles d'une montre et d'autres dans
l'autre sens et il y en a même qui
arrive à la voir un coup dans un sens un
coup dans l'autre ou comme la robe la
fameuse robe vous souvenez il y a une
partie des gens qui la voyait blanche et
dorée et l'autre partie qui la voyait
bleu et noir bon on va pas revenir
là-dessus on en a déjà assez parlé
elle était bleue et noire voilà bon le
coup de la robe vous vous en souvenez
sûrement parce que c'est relativement
récent mais en réalité ça fait très
longtemps qu'on utilise les illusions
d'optique dans l'art par exemple ça
c'est la chute d'eau des chair pas le
mec qui voulait déjeuner en paix l'autre
alors je sais pas si ça vous saute aux
yeux tout de suite mais suivez le canal
qui va jusqu'à la chute d'eau pour voir
voilà puis maintenant recommencer
il y a rien qui vous choque voilà si ce
genre de truc ça vous intéresse vous
pouvez chercher hop art ou arroptick on
a aussi inventé des jouets optiques qui
sont les ancêtres du cinéma et notamment
du cinéma d'animation et puis on a
utilisé les illusions d'optique dans le
domaine des neurosciences d'ailleurs les
mecs qui ont théorisé le coût du mur du
café là bah c'est des psychologues et
Akiyoshi Kitaoka pareil bon lui il fait
aussi des trucs pour Lady Gaga mais bon
chacun c'est hobbies ah encore une
pochette de disques bref tous ces trucs
dont on vient de parler ça date un petit
peu mais encore aujourd'hui on continue
de s'intéresser aux illusions d'optique
elles ont même leurs Oscars le concours
des meilleurs illusions de l'année oui
c'est factuel comme nom c'est carré
c'est organisé par une ONG qui aide la
recherche scientifique et médicale le
concours a même sa chaîne Youtube allez
jeter un oeil si vous voulez purement et
simplement péter votre crâne attention
cette vidéo est pas terminée laissez-moi
vous dire un petit mot sur notre sponsor
et sur le cadeau que je vous propose
donc panda craft je vous l'ai dit en
début de vidéo c'est des kits éducatifs
et scientifiques pour les enfants
jusqu'à 7 ans c'est explore et de 8 à 12
ans c'est makers dans les deux cas c'est
le même principe vous abonner à un
enfant de votre choix que vous
connaissez et qui est sympa par exemple
et tous les mois il reçoit son kit
directement chez lui dans ce kit il aura
un magazine éducatif avec plein de trucs
intéressants mais aussi une activité
manuelle un truc à fabriquer une
expérience à réaliser regardez comme je
suis habile de mes petits doigts
gracieux et comme j'ai l'air réveillé
donc tous les mois un nouveau kit et
tous les mois une nouvelle thématique ce
mois-ci c'est la vision ces raccords
avec la vidéo que vous venez de regarder
le mois prochain le thème ce sera les
mammouths et en décembre la Laponie ce
sera raccord avec la saison ou pas vu
l'état du climat mais ça c'était le
thème du mois d'avril si vous suivez
bien voilà donc comme je vous ai dit ça
marche par abonnement ça coûte 10 euros
et c'est sans engagement un cadeau cool
pour un enfant cool et comme d'habitude
je vais pas vous laisser repartir les
mains vides je vous offre moins 15% sur
les abonnements explore et makers avec
le code dans ton corps tout attaché vous
avez le lien dans la description vous
avez juste à cliquer dessus à vous
laisser guider et c'est parti le code
est valable jusqu'au 28 octobre 2022
donc faites vous plaisir voilà ce
coup-là DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de
vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]